hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my Walking Dead episode 6 video
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
it yet it was mostly a Tara episode but
they're just laying tracks for what will
become the season finale episode 16 in
the spring so there's some big stuff on
the horizon so we finally confirm
Oceanside a place that we've heard about
in the comics but haven't really seen
yet so they're moving this way up
Oceanside doesn't really debut or
actually doesn't even get mentioned till
issue like 138 but it's not like the
safe zone or the Savior's compound a
place where you go spend a bunch of time
it's just a place that we hear about
it's comprised of people that fish for
their food like they say they have an
unlimited supply of food so even with
that ambiguous ending you just have to
believe that they're gonna come back at
some point because they have weapons
they have unlimited food in surprise
surprise those just happen to be the
things that the safe zone needs so top
10 WTF and comic book Easter eggs and
just a really quick shout out just
because YouTube's doing some weird stuff
lately make sure you enable alerts if
you're subscribed just so that you get
all the videos because supposedly
YouTube's being weird but here we go
number 10 teryn Heath have been
scavenging for the last two weeks and
they haven't found anything so this is
where the timeline gets a little messed
up if you were confused because it
seemed like Terra didn't know about
anything that had happened even to
Denise because during the episode she
says I have a girlfriend I'd like to get
back to but we saw Denise died during
season six so already you know you're
kind of asking questions and they're
jumping around so really the answer to
that is that even though we've had six
plus episodes this season so far in a
couple last season since Denise died
they haven't been moving in real-time so
it's only been about two weeks since
Denise died I think that you know they
did this because of that last big moment
you know number nine when she actually
gets back and Eugene just breaks down it
tells her what's been going on
completely taking the wind out of her
sails sorry to hear about Denise like
the whole episode like the tone was
meant to be a little more hopeful like
Tara was all bubbly like hey we could
work together we can make this happen
and then she gets back finds out that
Denise is dead what the Savior's are
done it just completely breaks down so
number seven you know jumping around in
the timeline more
Taron Heath make it to the bridge Tara
accidentally just Yanks all those
walkers out of the sand it was a great
reveal it was like one of the big action
set pieces of the episode walker traps
are one of the most fun parts of Walking
Dead some are better than others this
one was pretty good but with the way
they broke that scene up in time across
the episode you're just left to wonder
how Tara wound up on the beach but then
you start to put the clues together like
oh she probably fell off the bridge and
got carried there so number six the
little girl Rachel which is absolutely
hilarious
reminds me of Carl from Season three
like little baby Carl with the gun who
was just totally ready to weigh someone
in fact she was making that downward
motion just as Cindy stopped her like
she stopped her mid stab before if she
could get Tara just absolutely hilarious
throughout the entire episode and as
Tara's leaving just totally flips her
off so number five though welcome to
Oceanside so like I said it's right out
of the comics but they haven't done a
whole lot with it in the comics yet so
they're moving this way up on the TV
show it's really just meant to broaden
the universe and lay tracks for what I
think will become all-out war but the
way they played it in this episode and
the fact that there are only two more
episodes before the end of the year made
me feel like it's gonna be a long time
before anybody gets their [ __ ] together
and they marshal their forces against
the Savior's so we met this community of
women who are pretty badass
but super nice and have unlimited food
we will definitely be going back there
in the future but it just feels like
it's not gonna happen for a while the
leader here in Netanya also not from the
comics but wasn't this just like the
most chill interrogation you've ever
seen on The Walking Dead ever like they
asked her if she wants to go to the
bathroom do you want some fish they
invite her to a sit-down dinner then ask
her to join the community and even offer
to let her friend they're talking about
Heath join too if they can find him so
these are like the nicest people ever if
this had been any other group they would
have just punched Tara in the face and
just thrown her out on the side of the
street for the walkers to take isn't it
just hilarious when you see something
like this and you think about what's
been happening to Daryl during his stay
at the Savior's compound having to
listen to that song
over and over and they're just doing
like arts and crafts out here at
Oceanside like it's no
big deal like if anything that almost
took me out of the episode like it just
felt way too nice for the walking dead
but again it just feels like it's all
set up for that big payoff at the end
when she learns about all the crap
that's happened I know some of you were
kind of disappointed that she isn't
alpha but that just means that they
could do whispers way way later so we
can talk about them if they ever tease
them on the show it seemed like there's
some other group in that weeks ahead
trailer that Rick in air and run into it
has absolutely nothing to do with
Oceanside so there's still a lot of
other new characters that they could
crawl out of the comic book woodwork
number four though what happened to all
the dudes so they explained that the
Savior's like it takes a while before
they both acknowledge that they've run
afoul of the Savior's but eventually the
woman's like oh the people that you went
to kill at the satellite station they're
the same people that killed all the men
everyone over a certain age and did you
catch what this woman said she dropped a
bomb on Tara like she made it sound like
them attacking that satellite station
set off the chain of events that caused
the death of all of their men and then
is going to lead to some greater
conflict but I think the problem there
is like you could blame the survivors
and Ric for making that decision to go
against the Savior's but they would have
arrived at this situation eventually no
matter what so even if you want to lay
blame technically they're not on the
wrong I think it all just depends on
whether or not you believe that true
evil exists in the world do you think
that negan is evil so just to give you
an idea for the geography a lot of
people were confused about the timeline
for the Oceanside community the men were
killed where they used to live they
bailed afterwards
in found ocean side then erected that
big barricade with the sand so the
Savior's have no idea where Oceanside is
that's why they're trying to keep it
such a secret but if you remember in
last week's episode Steven augs said
that there was another mutual group when
he was talking to Gregory that had been
taken care of and wasn't an issue
anymore he might have been referring to
the conflict the Savior's had with that
Oceanside group number three meet Cindy
she's not from the comics but she could
be in a mall gyum of characters they
could be turning her into like the
magnet character who's part of a
different community they're just so
the other groups of people that they
could introduce on the TV show so we can
talk about them if they actually
introduced them but for the most part
Cindy's just supposed to be this badass
character who is really hopeful you know
you don't choose to be evil you just
forget about who you are
so she's just meant to lay that seed
inside Tara but I love Tara's answer to
that I've seen evil it exists she's
talking about the saviors but it's kind
of funny because most of the audience
like me you guys were thinking about
negan when she's talking about evil
people really existing in the world but
she hasn't met negan yet she doesn't
know anything about that so when she's
talking about evil existing she was just
talking about the saviors at that
satellite station but it does kind of
make you remember her experience with
the governor like the birth of the fist
bump it was so long ago that she debuted
in that solo governor episode it seems
like it's been a long time but that was
way back during season four so number
two is Heath what happened to Heath
there are tracks making it seem like he
bailed in the RV and got away but
there's that little keycard with the P
symbols drawn on it which doesn't really
refer to anything that we've seen on the
show so far
it could belong to the saviors it could
be Heath trying to leave a clue or
something that he accidentally dropped
but Tara is just taking it as a sign
that Heath got away so they played it
super ambiguous just to make you feel
the anxiety of wondering what happened
to him but isn't it crazy that they
didn't address it when she got back to
the safe zone like she just learns about
Denise and is all bummed out they don't
address Heath at all like hey did Heath
come back where's the RV
there's no shots of it so that's just
some of the tricks that the Walking Dead
likes to play on you just like making
you wonder like what what happened to
him so you guys can let me know in the
comments did he's get back or was he
taken by the Savior's or another group
in that key car belonged to them but my
number one was just like the
conversation that you did not hear her
learning about all the crap that's
happened the last couple of weeks or the
last six episodes really Glenn and
Abraham were killed
negan is imposing this crazy rule on
them daryl is a prisoner everyone's in
shambles the Savior's have already taken
most of our supplies so we have nothing
but it did close the loop on like this
really hopeful arc like it definitely
balanced it out so let me know what was
your favorite moment from the
episode in how long do you think it's
gonna be before we see the Oceanside
people again like I feel like Cindy has
to come back they set her up is such a
badass character you can't just never
bring her back so there's gonna be some
huge war in the season finale I feel
like she is going to be a part of it the
real MVP of the episode though was
Rachel she was probably one of the best
new characters in this I hope they bring
her back even though I'm not expecting
her to be like a really huge character
the life expectancy of children on the
Walking Dead is usually pretty short
unless they're willing to kill she seems
like more of a Carl type character so
maybe they'll keep her around but what's
gonna happen next is I'll post my
Westworld video then I'll post a Walking
Dead trailer video and there is a new
round of the walking dead giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber leave a comment on this video
like I said just because YouTube is
being really weird make sure you turn
alerts on make sure that like little
Bell is grayed out so those and some
Rick and Morty is coming down the
pipeline too later this week maybe on
Tuesday I'm gonna be doing Rick and
Morty videos but all explain how that's
gonna work when I post that first video
while you guys wait for that to post you
can click here for the craziest game of
Thrones theories you've ever heard and
you can click here to start getting
ready for that big flash dc4 night
crossover this week so let's fist bump
I'll see you guys tonight